ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video se siete nuovi benvenuti nel canale a
proposito di canale ci stiamo
avvicinando al milione quindi ragazzi
datemi una mano anche voi se non vi siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi subito sì sì
ho fatto alcuni danni ultimamente
ma andiamo per step iniziamo dai saldi
cioé praticamente un decimo del video
partiamo da zara con i saldi ho comprato
molto poco da zara
ho preso questo e non l'ho ancora messo
per ovvie ragioni non lo so mi piaceva
però effettivamente non è che proprio
lo puoi mettere per andare a far la spesa sempre con i saldi e sempre della serie la
sobrietà prima di tutto
pantalone leopardato la sobrietà prima di
tutto viva le trasparenze non ho ancora
capito bene cosa ci metterò sotto
sicuramente o un body color carne o un
reggiseno carne o bianco non lo so da
valutare però mi piaceva indovinate un
pó
i saldi sono finiti tutto il resto è
nuova collezione direttamente dalla
moquette di casa della nonna
sempre da zara ho trovato lui non l'ho
ancora provato non provo i vestiti la
maggior parte delle volte non provo i
vestiti nei negozi perché troppa coda ai camerini non ho voglia di svestirmi adesso é inverno e
siamo pieni di roba
quindi dico li provo a casa al massimo
poi li cambio quindi non l'ho ancora
provato però mi ispira perché è stretto
dalla vita in giù ma verso il seno si
allarga e le maniche sono un pò larghe vi
farò sapere
lo passi o lo bombi poi stiamo entrando
un pó in modalità sobrio pantalone che
anche questo devo ancora provare provare
sempre di zara
io ho un problema coi pantaloni di zara
perché spesso l'xs che é la mia taglia
mi sta larga quindi questo qua lo proverò
capirò se lo bombo o lo passo rosa
sigaretta vita alta con una bella
camicetta dentro una décolleté e si vola
pronta per piccole donne con questa
camicia over size con questo fantastico
colletto con delle
con dei fili di perle che insomma pendono dal colletto finiamo gli
acquisti da zara con una fantastica
anche questa camicia con i bottoni i
dettagli oro over size di ecopelle
ovviamente che me la sono subito
immaginata o con un vestito molto
aderente magari anche un tubino nero e
questa aperta così magari anche un po
abbassata all'ariana grande della serie
ce l'ho ma non ce l'ho oppure niente me
la sono immaginata così o così o niente
da other stories ho preso solo un
maglione è un negozio che mi piace ma
appunto non trovo spesso cose nel mio
stile
quindi è uno di quelli
in cui guardo tutto ma mi attira poca
roba
lui mi attirava perché perché faceva
molto taylor swift che suona con la
chitarra in un locale delle campagne del
texas
passiamo da h&m ho preso questa
gonna verde militare perché mi ricordava
tantissimo una gonna che mettevo alle
medie era praticamente uguale ma invece
di esser a vita alta come va adesso era
un po più a vita bassa da h&m era un
trionfo di verde militare e robe
mimetiche tant'è che mi sono fatta
convincere cioé mi sono convinta da sola a
prendere anche questa t shirt
non so quanto la userò ma mi sembrava
molto teen poi ho preso questa felpa
che è molto sksksk vsco girl finiamo in bellezza con un
bel vestito mimetico aderente
lo so che é da tutto il video che
ovviamente puntate questi sacchetti infatti li ho lasciati per il finale per un motivo
andiamo con ordine sapete che adoro
maje e ho preso questo cappotto che
volevo da una vita modello io lo
chiamo non so se si chiama così "accappatoio"
perché accappatoio perché appunto
sembra un accappatoio quindi cintura in vita e si va
a comandare
l'ho preso perchè mi sono immaginata un
attimo in modalità sarah jessica parker
in sex and the city
io che scendo a prendere un caffè da
starbucks così con la prima cosa che
trovo quindi sotto in pigiama pigiama di
seta sopra questo cappotto chiuso
così velocemente per andare a prendere
il caffè perché senza caffè non può
partire la mia giornata
passiamo a jimmy choo questo è il mio
primo paio di scarpe della vita no il mio primo paio di jimmy choo prima andavo in giro
scalza il mio primo paio di jimmy choo e vii avviso già è proprio basic nel senso
la roba più classica del mondo però
avevo bisogno di questa tipologia di scarpa
e volevo che fosse una scarpa di qualità
che mi durasse e resistente buona
comfort top delle normalissime décolleté
nere di vernice tacco 10 perché sono
molto comode io le voglio usare magari per gli eventi giornate e serate in cui
devo stare in piedi tanto quindi
volevo la comodità prima di tutto nere
perché ovviamente una décolleté nera non può mai mancare nella scarpiera di una
donna nella mia è mancata fino
adesso non so come ho fatto a vivere ci
avviciniamo anzi siamo arrivati a due
bambine bambine piccole devo dire ma
meravigliose da quale partiamo qui non si capisce neanche cos é perché é girato
quindi decisione difficile partiamo da
lei da lui lei o lui? non ha sesso
allora volevo un marsupio di gucci da
tantissimo tempo avevo adocchiato quelli
di velluto ma trovano il tempo che
trovano nel senso che li puoi
mettere soltanto durante l'inverno non è
che a maggio oa giugno tu mi vai in giro
con il borsello di velluto almeno io non
mi sento di metterlo magari si può
mettere non lo so questa é la mia opinione
quindi avevo accantonato questa idea
però l'idea del marsupio di una cosa
comoda ma anche chic mi gironzolava da
un pó in testa poi
ho visto lui ed è stato colpo di fulmine
ma bando alle ciance vi faccio vedere
subito cioé capito top ma non è finita
qui perché se non lo volete mettere in
vita lo potete mettere può anche essere
messo così però scusami eh se io metto
dentro volendo una volta la voglio usare la
da pochette ma dai ma ragazzi ma di cosa parliamo
metto dentro le catene e la uso così quindi tutti e due avevo ragione io è un ibrido un
gender fluid poi entro in un altro
negozio uno dei miei preferiti di borse
e accessori e penso ma scusate io
scusate scusa perché parlavo con me stessa
la pochette nera ce l'ho il marsupio ce l'ho lo zainetto di moschino ce l'ho la borsa da
tutti i giorni ce l'ho però che cos'è
che ogni volta che esco che ho
un'occasione speciale mi manca poi ho un attimo girato lo sguardo e ho visto lei
che mi faceva così : "ehi baby, vieni"
io tipo occhi a cuore
quasi come la prada e vi giuro che anche
qui c'è stata una mezza scena con una
cinese che l'aveva adocchiata cioè io non so
che problemi abbia con queste situazioni qua ve la faccio vedere quanto é meravigliosa è una
di quelle borse che tu puoi usare in
qualsiasi occasione
jeans giacca di pelle primavera un pó
scollata comunque casual
tu dici che cosa ci aggiungo per perché
questo look sia casual chic top of the
pops lei evento di gala vestito
elegante lungo scarpa nude
cosa manca lei bikini in spiaggia infradito
cosa ti manca lei no a parte gli scherzi è una
borsa che puoi mettere in molte occasioni ma soprattutto è bellissima poi ovviamente
c'è sempre l'oro ho tradito l'oro nero
questo è un nude oro beige oro
si può mettere sia a tracolla che così
doppia
e niente io sono follemente innamorata
con la mia nuova bambina abbiamo
terminato il video haul
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere qui sotto
che cosa avete preferito o meglio perché
io conosco
noi donne quale tra le due borse avete
preferito che una donna guarda questo
video vede solo le borse il resto non gliene frega niente quindi
fatemi sapere quale dei due acquisti top avete preferito
vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al
prossimo video mi raccomando se non l' avete
fatto iscrivetevi al canale e seguitemi
su instagram e tiktok per vedere le
foto di questi outfit di questi
accessori indossati
ciao adoro